what was it like working with steve jobs
what uh aspect of his behavior and
personality
let's say brought out the best in you
pushing you
really pushing you relentless on the
details
challenging you
for the right reasons
it wasn't bullying it wasn't demeaning
he would critique the work not judge the
person at least not in front of them
uh or inside of a you know in front of a
group or anything like that
i know it was really that attention to
detail and
he when he would make a decision you
know there are when you make the first
version of anything something
revolutionary there are a lot of
opinion-based decisions and there's only
one or two people three people who hold
those opinion-based decisions and what
they should be
and
when you have those opinions
and you're trying to work with the team
to
implement those
decisions
you have to really tell the why of those
decisions just don't go do it but why
it's there so you can feel part of that
decision you can understand
what were the trade-offs of the
different other
answers to that opinion right
and say this is the reason why we picked
the what we picked because it's this for
the customer or this for the overall
story what have you so that you felt
really good
because a lot of times most people want
a data driven decision
but with v1s you don't get data
right maybe in a b2b you could a little
bit because you can talk to customers
but you can't do that with a consumer
property one version one b2b business
the business versus what's the
alternative
uh business to consumer vb okay
which is defining centers
yes
so and when you say data-driven
decisions versus what
opinion-based decisions so like gut you
have to use you don't have any
um
you can't fall back on any data or any
previous history to kind of inform you
of what's going on right and so if you
look at most
companies who are paralyzed and cannot
make new innovations and new products
it's because they're trying to turn and
this is what i saw at phillips they're
trying to turn opinion-based decisions
into data-driven decisions so they don't
lose their jobs
so if you look at management consulting
management consulting is all about
taking those opinion-based decisions
giving them to someone else to turn into
data that comes back to them and says
they can blame the management
consultants yeah when something goes
wrong as opposed to it wasn't me
yeah right
when you need to have to tell that story
you have to understand that especially
v1 you need to be able to
um
articulate those those
opinion-based decisions and you need to
own them
and if you fail with some of them you
didn't get it right you you then
own them and fix them and move on right
version one of the ipod wasn't perfect
version one of the iphone wasn't perfect
we got a lot of opinion-based decisions
wrong
but as you go through because you got
more data because v2 you had data on
those original opinions and then you
were able to then modulate off of that
right and you still have new opinions
because those are differentiators that
you that we call differentiators that
the things that you know move the move
the product forward um in its evolution
but at the revolution stage opinions
opinions opinions no data and so you
have this discussion you and steve and
the whole in the stage and the whole
team
uh with opinions
and there you have to be harsh
i i wouldn't say harsh but you have to
be very determined right you know
there are two real opinion-based
decisions that happened on the iphone
one was
the keyboard
should we have a key hardboard keyboard
or should we have a virtual keyboard
the blackberry was the number one
productivity messaging device of its
time
it was called a crackberry for a reason
because people loved it because it had
it was easy to type and you know they
could get their work done
but when you're saying we're gonna move
from that everyone's talking about that
in the market and you say we're going to
move to a virtual keyboard and it's not
going to work as well as the hardware
keyboard
that's an opinion-based decision right
because the data is telling you
yeah all the best sales are over here
god that takes cuts
it takes guts but you have to look at it
from a different point of view and this
is how
i learned to come to understand this
because i had been building you know
virtual keyboards before and i knew
you know the goodness and the badness in
them right but he was like look those
are productivity devices we're making it
where ours is born out of an
entertainment device and productivity
right
we need to show full screen videos we're
going to have apps not apps but our apps
the apple apps because there were no app
store yet are going to take over the
whole screen you want a full screen web
browser you don't want one that's like
half of the device is just a keyboard
maybe you don't need that keyboard in
every instance so we want that part of
the screen to change based on the tool
you may need at the time and maybe it's
just full view right so you have to go
and understand it's a different type of
device just because that's that and it's
successful for that reason the
crackberry for the keyboard that's not
the only thing you're going to do with
this device because people only did
messaging and maybe a few phone calls
right this was going to be so much more
it was going to be an entertainment web
browsing device so you wanted those
tools to go away but it wouldn't be as
good
as the hardware keyboard so that's an
opinion but let me give you another
opinion based decision that got turned
around before it shipped
steve said no sim slot
i don't want any slots we're going to
make it very pure
johnny was like of course no slots
johnny
and
we all looked around go that doesn't
work you can't do that well why does
variety and then he would always and
this was the magic of steve like when
you said no that doesn't work you go
well why does verizon not have any sim
slots
right they showed that you can do a
mobile phone with those limits and
you're like
okay here we go and so
a few days later we come back with
you know and and so uh product marketing
voice of the customer engineering we all
come back with all the data showing how
many
how many data networks and mobile
networks required sim cards versus did
not
and what the trends were and we showed
the data
and that killed the or excuse me brought
back the sim slot on the original iphone
because we're like
he because he was just like we're going
to tell a t to not use a sim yeah right
we're going to just tell him to do it
differently right but we were like if we
want this thing to go anywhere around
the world you want to put that friction
in people are going to move from place
to place you know they have different
sims because of the prices and all that
stuff we had to show all of that data
and then that opinion-based decision got
turned into a data-driven decision and
it and the sim slot obviously showed up
so those are two ver at the very same
time yeah right
opinion can hold and so can data
overrule opinion when data does exist
for a v1 but the at the end of the day
you don't know what the right answer is
so
doing no
uh sim card slot
may have been the right decision
we won't know
because maybe if that was
the decision
then like many times throughout apple's
history you basically change the tide
of how technology is done
yeah absolutely you know you never know
apple started wi-fi people don't
understand wi-fi came out of there there
was no wi-fi in 2001. apple started
wi-fi and then everyone else you know
got onto on board if you look at now
where we're going we're going to phones
without sim slots
because we have e sims right and now the
sim slots becoming legacy legacy as a
legacy port
that legacy portal probably be gone by
six maybe ten years he'll be gone i'm
pretty sure of that
um because it's so much easier for
carries they don't have to have physical
things to go out and right
so right now it's just the early days
but it will happen and it will go its
way it'll fall away but it will take
time you just couldn't do it back then
so timing is essential here but at the
end of the day it's opinions and that's
where the genius is sometimes the data
tells you one thing but the data at the
end of the day does represent the past
exactly and the future may be different
than the past right
uh sometimes there's wisdom in the in
the past and sometimes
it's actually representative of
something that should be
overcome and
progress looks like leaving that stuff
behind
you